هؤلاء بعض الصغار فنلندا التي صنفت انها
اسعد دوله في العالم ظلت كذلك ست سنوات
رغم الخوف الذي سببه لها غزو جارتها روسيا
لاوكرانيا خوف ربما بدا يتلاشى قليلا
بتاكيد انضمامها الوشيك الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي قبل ايام فقط من الانتخابات
العامه اولويه الامن امر يتفق عليه الجميع
رغم اختلافهم في قضايا اخرى كثيره
وان نكون جزءا من النيتو
تغيرنا كثيرا وبسرعه هذا العام السؤال
يدور بشان القضايا الداخليه مثل البيئه
والصحه والتعليم
من المهم جدا ان نظل ملتزمين بالاتحاد
الاوروبي واهداف التحول الى الطاقه
الخضراء لان هذه هي الامور التي يعرف بها
هذا البلد
في الانتخابات الفنلنديه كل صوت يفرط
فاستطلاعات الراي الاخيره تظهر فوارق
طفيفه تندرج في هامش الخطا بين الاحزاب
الرئيسيه الثلاثه تتشكل الحكومات
الفنلنديه في العقود الاخيره من ائتلافات
بين الاحزاب دون ان يتفرد احدها بالحكم
لكن توازنات القوى قد تسقط رئيسه الوزراء
الحالي
حتى لو كانت رئيسه الوزراء نجمه سياسيه
دوليه فهي لا تبدو كذلك في فنلندا وهناك
الكثير من التحديات التي تواجهها واهمها
الاقتصاديه بسبب الديون الكبيره التي
تكبدتها البلاد خلال حكمها طبعا بسبب وباء
كورونا والحرب في اوكرانيا
مثلتنا مارين ظاهره سياسيه جديده في
فنلندا واوروبا تصف المناهضين للمهاجرين
بالعنصريين والمطالبين بالخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالاغبياء وتقول دون تردد ان
روسيا يجب ان تهزم في اوكرانيا هي سيده
صغيره تتحدث بلغه لم يعدها الناس في هذا
البلد من السياسيين
الاهتمام عندما اصبحت اصغر رئيسه وزراء
منتخبات في العالم قبل اقل من ثلاث سنوات
ونصف
فشاهد التغييرات تاريخيه وجيو استراتيجيه
كبيره تجعل اعاده انتخاب
ها سيمثل النجاح فيه رصيدا اضافيا
لمسيرتها السياسيه محمد المدهون الجزيره
هل سينكي